I am currently right now at Hilton
Dallas in Park City and we have 450
entrepreneurs in there who are
absolutely going bonkers you'll see
their energy right now no matter but one
of the things that I think we don't talk
about enough is entrepreneurs generally
struggle with two things two things in
business one you're either getting tired
too quickly you're getting tired too
quickly so it's a fatigue issue you have
or two you have an endurance issue
stamina issue you don't last long enough
to give yourself an opportunity to
survive leadership fatigue factor is you
can't go long for a day
leadership endurance factor is you can't
go along for 6 12 24 36 48 5 years until
you get the results both are necessary
once you get both down you are giving
yourself a higher percentage of being
able to make it in business and I want
to kind of give you a flavor what this
energy looks like here today with these
450 entrepreneurs we have here in Dallas
now let's get in there get ready for
them getting ready for getting ready for
it
gotta be kidding your life that was
going on in you guys it's just like
we're talking business here Weiss Weiss
everybody so quiet
yeah
happy ah
ah
I will
Oh